يحذر مجددا من كارثه نوويه عالميه مقتل
شخص واصابه العشرات في زلزالا جديدا
بتركيا تفاصيل جديده حول مقتل عارضه
الازياء بهونج كونج هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في عوده الروسيه الى الحديث عن الحرب
النوويه قال ديمتريث مجلس الامن الروسي
والرئيس الروسي السابق قال ان استمرار
الغرب في تزويد كييف بالاسلحه قد يقود
لكارثه نوويه عالميه تصريحات في اعقاب
تحذير نوويا اطلقه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الاسبوع الماضي وتصريح صدر عنه امس
الاحد وصف فيه المواجهه بين موسكو والغرب
بانها معركه وجوديه لروسيا وشعبها
رعب الهزات الارضيه لا يزال مستمرا في
تركيا حيث ضرب زلزال جديد بقوه 5.6 درجات
على مقياس ريختر ولايه ملاطيا جنوب البلاد
ما ادى الى وقوع قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه حذرت
المواطنين في ملاطيا من الاقتراب من
المباني المتضرره شره الى ان فرق الاغاثه
توجهت الى هذه المنطقه فيما تشهد تركيا
العديد من الهزات الارتداديه منذ زلزال
المدمر في السادس من الشهر
في احدث تفاصيل الجريمه المروعه التي
شهدتها هونغ كونغ مثل افراد من عائله
الزوج السابق لعارضه الازياء والمؤثره على
مواقع التواصل ابيتشوي امام المحكمه بتهمه
قتلها الشرطه في هونغ كون كانت اعتقلت
المتهمين وهم زوجها السابق ووالده واخوه
بعد العثور على اشياء من جسدها في ثلاجه
منزلهم بعد ايام من اختفائها ويعتقد ان
الشاب كان لديها نزاعات ماليه تتعلق
بعشرات الملايين من الدولارات مع زوجها
السابق وعائلته
جريمه من نوع اخر في اسبانيا حيث قبضت
الشرطه الاسبانيه على عصابه الكترونيه
يتزعمها قاصر احتالت على 200 عميلا مصرفي
واستولت على 350 الف يورو من اموالهم خلال
شهرين الى جانب زعيم العصابه القاصر الذي
لم يتم الكشف عن عمره قبضت الشرطه على 24
اخرين من هذه العصابه وهي التي سرقت
بيانات من خلال رسائل البريد الكتروني
احتياليه ورسائل نصيه قصيره ورسائل على
تطبيق واتساب ومكالمه هاتفيه
في موقع اثري باقليم شمال غربيه الصين عثر
علماء الاثار على زلاجات جليد اثريه
مصنوعه من عظام الحيوانات يرجع تاريخها
الى اكثر من 3000 عام وكاله الانباء
الصينيه نقلت عن رئيس الفريق الاثري ان
زلاجات الجليد العظميه المذكوره اكتشفت في
موقع دفن كبيرا يعود تاريخه الى الفتره ما
بين القرنين السادس عشر والخامس عشر قبل
الميلاد فيما خلص العلماء الى ان الزلاجات
مصنوعه من عظام الماشيه والخيول وان شكلها
وبنيتها متماثلان تقريبا مع نظيراتها
القديمه الموجوده في اوروبا